learn how to build a full stack
application using chat GPT in this
course you'll learn how to Leverage The
Power of chat GPT to accelerate your
development process and make programming
smoother Judy is a full stack developer
and teacher in this course she'll
demonstrate how to build an educational
application using chat GPT to ask
questions about coding syntax
troubleshooting and learning best
practices you'll also discover how to
use chat GPT to build various features
including authentication browsing
courses and creating categories so let's
get started and see how chat GPT can
help you build amazing applications with
minimal manual coding hello everyone
this is Judy and in this video I'll show
you how to use chat GPT on every step of
the way for full stack development one
of the benefits of chat GPT is its
abilities of accelerating development
and making programming or learning
process much smoother during this one
walkthrough will build an educational
application and you're going to see that
minimal manual coding is done but don't
take my word for it watch the tutorial
examples of questions we will ask chat
GPT include coding syntax
troubleshooting learning best practices
and receiving guidance on picking the
right tools and platform for your
project also using it into our
application will build various features
such as authentication browsing courses
its categories and many more I'm
thrilled to present various prompts I
have explored and demonstrate how you
can make most of charge GPT so without
further delay let's dive right into it
when using chatgpt as a coding assistant
it's important to provide the right
context the model has been trained on
various kinds of data and its default
answers can be quite generic however by
providing more specific information we
can achieve better results with that in
mind I'm gonna ask it to act as a
developer so I'll say I want you to act
as a software developer I will provide
some specific information and this is
where we give it indications as to what
its mission is throughout this
conversation which is to come up with an
architecture for developing easy to use
course app
so far this description contains very
general information the goal of this app
is to allow users to take online courses
on different subjects and Below let's
list uh features we want the app to
include which is going to be
authentication courses and their
categories we also want course search
payments and functionality of saving
courses
as an answer chai GPT proposes an
architecture and provides a division of
the stack it offers as you can see
sections for both front-end and back-end
development with suggestions for tools
and approaches within each section let's
review the list and furthermore you can
reuse this template the description May
differ depending on the situation but
still could be useful reference for your
future projects
and if you want more comprehensive
guidelines on building full stack apps
check out my notion template for full
stack roadmap I have included all the
parts of the stack as well as the topics
and resources you would need to build
applications and yeah check the link in
the description if you're interested
all right let's go over the list now we
have user interface developer responsive
user-friendly UI using modern
Technologies such as react and angular
to provide an intuitive and engaging
user experience so for the
authentication a scalable solution and
it provided us with options of os JWT
and open ID connect these are indeed I
would say one of the most popular
authenticate ways of authenticating
users then we have course listings
display in user-friendly allow users to
browse and search Implement filters and
sorting options for enhanced visibility
okay most of the searches do have indeed
filters and different options so for
sorting that's good
payments are processed through two
common Solutions stripe and PayPal and
additionally we have course details
course progress tracking and the ability
to save progress to your profile
let's take a look at the back end what
components do we need first we need an
API so that the data can be communicated
between the backend and the front end
using a back-end framework such as
node.js Django or laravel once we have
that we can focus on the database chat
GPT answer mentions mongodb in MySQL and
postgresql as examples but these are
very different solutions and to get
started let's pick one database and
gather as many details as possible about
it so I'm gonna say let's start with
database how would you structure it and
would you pick relational over
non-relational here if you don't know
the differences between the two you can
also ask what kind of databases are
there in general so it would give return
list of like descriptions and
differences and it does suggest to our
question to use both and let's
understand what's the reasoning behind
it
so consistency and Clarity are crucial
when defining relationships between
entities such as profiles and courses
well it's straightforward to determine
whether a user is enrolled in a course
or not tracking course progress can vary
significantly between user and courses
therefore doesn't require strict
consistency and I agree with the
statement uh we do not need like a very
structured data for progress but we do
uh need a more clear definitions for
courses and the profiles entities itself
let's dive into the courses table and I
would say how would you structure
courses and charge GPT
returns fields for the table but we can
also ask it to print the output in a
tableer format for better with
visualization so that's another prompt
to remember and this is the stage where
you you can request notifications and
iterations before jumping into building
the app since this would drive the core
functionalities I would recommend taking
enough time to think about it however
don't spend too much time on it not to
delay the start of the project and when
it comes to getting assistance from chai
GPT it's good to have this like
step-by-step approach so for example I
don't want to add the metadata so I'm
going to ask can you remove metadata
from the table and it should uh output a
new table without it
and now we can start thinking how can
this table can be translated into a code
so I'm going to ask it to generate a
Prisma file that is where we Define a
schema for our database
so it's good that it also marks for
example course ID that can be used as a
primary key and it also gives us
explanation because this is the first
time we're using Prisma in this
conversation so it would Define the
prism as a modern database toolkit that
provides typesafe and then intuitive way
to define data models and interact with
databases in various programming
languages and to note even though this
is created in Prisma it depends on what
kind of language or database you're
using it with and this is also
indication where we can give it more
details also if let's say you already
have used Prisma and you don't want
extra explanations we can just use this
prompt code only and it will be faster
if you're generating a big code and want
it quicker
okay so now my next question would be
how can I use this with the backend that
I have picked
and this will give us what Super Bass is
which is an open source alternative to
the Firebase and let's see what else it
tells us about it uh here's how you can
set up prismap for Super Bass suppose
uses postgresql and it's also providing
us with the information that this is
relational type of database so I'm going
to list all the parts of the stack that
I'm planning to use and instead of me
going into for example three different
documentations because I want to use
actually a super bass and Tailwind the
charge Deputy should give me all the
steps so I don't have to like go look
for it and on top of that if any of the
two technologies uh that I will be using
are not compatible for example charger
PT should also point that out and once
it's done printing I'm gonna follow the
steps uh here with some modifications
first step is to run the command to
create next app and for that I'm gonna
open up a terminal and paste the command
here as and select the configurations
for my next this app
I do see that it says that the next step
to install Prisma but I think Super Bass
should have its own client and we can
check that with chatgpt
the answer that we got is that we do
need a client module which is super
based JS and it also provided a install
command and an example how to use it
with the courses table so going back to
the terminal going to I think it named
it my web app and then inside here copy
code
while this is installing
um another thing that was mentioned here
is how to set up Super Bass
so that would include creating a new
project and obtain connection URL for
your super based database and you'll
need this URL to connect your next.js
app to Super Bass so let's go and do
that I'm going to open this up I already
have an account and so I'm gonna sign in
create a new project I'll name it course
app for password I'm going to let it
generate and then copy
press create now we need to get the
connection URL that was mentioned here
let's ask um tell Chad GPT what it
thinks is the best choice for ID for
this project I do use vs code and I
think you also suggest us to use that
and when starting a project with a new
stack it's also helpful to check what
extensions are available to use with it
they can assist you in your development
process especially when it comes to
different kinds of files and syntax
highlighting error handling this is what
some of the things that extensions can
provide so asking what extensions would
you recommend to install for this Tech
stack
okay and now it's listing them
arranged into like categories
and you can install I think I have most
of this already
um this extensions
so to continue working on the project
I'm going back to the instructions that
it gave us it didn't specify which file
to write this code so I'm going to ask
it I also want the whole application to
have access to the Super Bass client
which file should I implement this and
how can I use that implementation of
in-app file
that's great all right let's do this
let's create inside our source new file
and yeah that is a cleaner way of
separating the initiation of an instance
of the service let's copy this code I'm
going to paste it and let's ask how we
can add environment variables
it's going to tell us to create a new
EnV local file and make sure to add that
in so it's a good thing that it tells us
it should be ignored to prevent it from
being committed in a Version Control
I've seen a lot of developers make a
mistake of accidentally committing their
API Keys which is like very sensitive
information
um and end up getting like a crazy high
bill from their providers
so to prevent that let's
um add those configurations in
copy the code and paste it here
so that's our first this goes in yeah
okay so then it even gives us the format
of
how it should look like and let's copy
this from
our project so I'm trying to see where
did the oh here it is
so yeah it probably got example from
here and
I'm gonna copy this
replace
it with it
and super bass key then that's the key
okay now I'm Gonna Save my changes also
for the super super bass file and let's
open up the terminal and run
the command and then render so we can
start our development instance and
navigate to localhost to result in where
our next GS app should show up now the
next piece is that so what we did with
basis basically we connected our app to
our project in the Super Bass and now
let's ask T what it thinks about like
writing the schema I did ask it already
scheme in Prisma but there's an option
to do that also without a prism on so
let's see what it says so
push my schema to newly created
supervised project and do you
recommend using
Prisma for this course app or
just
super based client
yeah so it gave us this Prisma setting
up Prisma steps but I want to know what
it says about just defining as for
whether to use Prisma or super based
client it depends on your specific
requirements and preferences a powerful
way to interact including Super Bass it
offers Advanced features
Etc
so it does say that just going with
Super Bass and it is more suitable for
smaller projects or when you prefer more
lightweight approach without the
advanced features a limited choice so
okay let's say if it's we did do Peak
the smaller model more lightweight
approach what it's gonna propose instead
foreign
the first thing that I want to do is I
want to add the course table so how can
I push that to the Super Bass and it
does give me the code that it already
printed out but once you have
crude operations okay
but this is just the functions on the
clients that we actually need to add the
table here so we can do that also by
doing manually but since we're using
chat GPT let's figure out a way how can
we get that from the script so
let's see can you write a script for a
SQL editor in Super Bass maybe you'll
understand that one
table for the project
here's okay great
now let's copy this one you can execute
this on the SQL query or any SQL editor
that is connected to your projects to
create courses table
let's see let's just select table and
I'm gonna select all of this paste this
in and click run where's this here
success no rows return now next part
after creating schema is sitting the
database can you as
first in Saving the database
what script can I run to add
some rows to
course table
and this should generate Us by like some
sample courses that it will come up with
so for example we have and it follows
like the
structure so it will create some dummy
data names descriptions
Etc and let's copy the code and run it
into
here
let's go to the table see if the have
been the data has been added here
great so now we are we have the data so
we're ready to copy the
this code that it wrote for us on the
client side inside the app we can
display the data so it created some
functions
so crude operations okay
perfect but before we go to the crude
let's just display the data and as I
remember
it created this font okay like get
function
here now I'm gonna ask it to create a
component that lists all the courses
yeah so it also takes in the context
that it told us to add this Super Bass
file in the loop folder so that's great
though it doesn't show how to set up in
the beginning and now I'm gonna copy the
code and let's see where it tells us to
save this file
okay let's just
create a new folder for components
and of course
with jsx
we can
paste it in here first add that into
the main page which is
index.js so I'm gonna
remove all this extra code
here oops
let's do import what kind of export
default okay import course list
from and this is
components
okay assuming I imported that correctly
await
Super Bass from okay so we need to
update
let's see export default super piece
okay so what it did mistake is the
import statement
is I should be asked for default and
here we get the list of courses
The Next Step would be as we start
creating more components and we're gonna
have more files asking it about file
structure best practices is also naming
conventions of these files to recommend
the file structure for an xjs using
Super Bass and Tailwind should be
following okay so and then it took into
the considerations that we have several
features and divided the page into the
features so in xjs if you're not already
familiar the way you create a page and
the new link is by creating files inside
of pages folder so it created login sign
up dashboard um
page for us and also in courses we have
the list of the courses course ID and
the new creation codes which is pretty
impressive as for components layout is
what we use like reasonable things in
the layout for example header footer Etc
it did create all of those and I guess
the course card the component for
displaying a course card okay
interesting and then we have a setup for
Super Bass and tailwind and some styling
usually we don't have much in the global
assistance and the entailing file any
custom code that you update to the
Tailwind or like setting a thing goes
there and let's see the explanation so
you just go through uh what I mentioned
and for naming conventions it's
recommended to use descriptive so it
offers us two cases camel case and a
kebab case
so let's see which one it went for of
course
you can name files related to course
with course as a prefix okay so course
list that we already have that and then
detail similarly you can follow similar
conventions and let's see how it named
the components with yeah the capitalize
first okay
now let's ask it to create course card
for to rewrite course list using the
course card
and let's also ask it to do the styling
like of how we want so for courses let's
display them in Grid and also let's ask
it to create card with some like Shadows
borders Etc so we can all describe it to
it and let's see what kind of how
exactly does The Styling um
foreign
will actually do that but we don't have
images at the moment and since this is
just such a UI it won't be able to
generate the images but we can ask it to
create like something that looks like a
thumbnail using using the styling
I don't know something like that
all right so I'm going to stop January
because
it gave a sample course Theta when it
should uh
take the course data from the super base
and
maybe because we asked it to do the
colors okay can you use get course
function from supervised that is why
it's good to be as detailed as possible
let's see if it's
okay Pages courses
and then it added some classes for The
Styling
make sure to import
and if we say continue it should
continue because we also ask for the
course card yeah here it is
yeah if you ever see or sometimes it
cuts off in the middle of the word
because it hits character limits so just
say continue generate background color
oh interesting so it actually did a
colorful and text loss based on course
title okay
let's get to components course card
and I don't think I updated this one
but
Pages courses let's create courses
folder
not the file
in the localhost we can navigate
two courses
can't result prop types you can ask it
to remove or we can just remove it
ourselves and just let it know that next
time don't add prop types so that was in
course card or we also install it
depends on the preferences
okay class names so let's install the
class name since
npm install
s
so it is a good library to use like
when defining when making conditional
statements in Tailwind
so okay courses
what about components
can I read properties of undefined okay
so it messed up the
import statement of Super Bass
so if we ask it to
next time let's see what it says
yes
default settings
okay then it'll go as a data version
and we do have courses
okay so there's no price just the title
and the description
background white so this is supposed to
be
the image and
text font interesting
background I PJ
yeah those are definitely not the Colors
Let's just set this to Gray and this one
as well
now let's move on to authentication and
see how we can Implement that using
charge repeating
we want to use super bass
oath and we want to ask how to create
Pages or how to protect our pages so
which pages are going to be for
authenticated users and Etc it's going
to tell us how to set that
will tell we are setting
location
after courses page
let's see if we have super bass UI might
not be installed so I'm going to copy
that
and
display oh it does come with UI so we
don't have to create a separate and now
protectors and Pages it's going to show
us how to have like courses display only
on four authorized users let's see if we
don't it by default selected Google for
us providers
we'll have to configure Google so let's
see if we can give us
authentication only by you username and
password
okay so this credentials is what's gonna
add end options custom DIY change your
email to your desired username field
okay
yeah we don't want to use the custom
methods just okay it's just showing us
now let's check if one thing is users
can actually sign in and sign up but
another is creating user table so let's
see if this is actually gonna create a
user table that we can get information
like email of users from because in
Firebase for example we have to create a
separate
like table where we can reference user
ID in firestore so let's see
because if not then we can also ask to
create a custom signup function where we
do that a little crazy those table okay
so just important questions
that's great
and now it's giving us the function when
we can fetch courses that users take
Taking later on we can also ask once we
have the users created for us to map
some courses to it but first okay let's
get started with this
installing the UI
piece first
npm install
UI
this we already have a layout
if we don't I think let's reference the
file structure that it proposed
which is here and in components we can
create layout Js
we still want to check Imports if it
looks correct import Tailwind
so we don't need to import Tailwind I'm
gonna remove that render
authentication UI render the last of the
layout okay and then children
go here
perfect now we can take this layout and
add it to our either index page or
courses page
let's add it to the courses page so
and then
this is export default
and I'm gonna wrap
the rest of the components inside
the layout here
and resolve
what is that
oh it's inside components
Super Bass is not defined it would be
nice
to like have a list of few things that
we want to remind it every time because
I think it did uh
they actually didn't import super bass
at all
okay that's not working well Google we
don't have the configured
let's do credentials
okay oh and the next year is
documentation so I'm gonna follow that
instead since we're getting errors and
apparently there's a helper's library
for next year we had the one for react
but probably this one is more suitable
so let's I'm gonna go ahead install it
and also follow the directions here
additionally install for react
components and hooks so we do already
have that one installed and setting up
environment retrieve your project URL
for API settings we did already set the
environment variables we since we
connected to Super Bass but we should
check because it's probably using this
very specific names like this helper
function so I should probably check if
our names are matching that would be in
the in re variable so yeah here it's
using a non-key instead of the key and
public
public supervisor see ya Let's update
this one
save it and also let's update it was
used in only in Super Bass files so
yep so we
need to change it and once we update the
environment variables let's
rerun
the application
after that there's like a basic setup
code that's provided to us that's in
pages app.js and going to that I'm gonna
copy this and let's leave the Styles
declaration everything else we should
have that and
I think this should be export default
yeah
exports
default
okay cool
Super Bass is not defined because
oops
reading dark okay let's double check the
documentation for
auth UI so we have UI react and also I
shared
so this one is coming from theme is
coming from author I shared so actually
this
code that we got from Chad GPT is
incorrect so I'm gonna go ahead and
install this
package I think that should be it for
setup or we don't really need to use
like a dark theme so let's
remove this and
follow this one here
maybe yeah we can also try create client
or super based clients just passing the
one we already have instead of
this function but
let's see if it's gonna work oh okay
so we got the login page it looks great
and now what we can do is
this is inside layout
okay so let's change the logic
if the session is not there then
display the auth
and if it's there we can show the
children
[Music]
I'll perform just the code for the
container
and it's class names
responsive let's say full with on
mobile
so height Flex item Center justify
content
Etc and then we have another
uh that so this is how you can also
utilize
to create responsive Styles because
sometimes it's tedious to Define
separate cells for mobile desktop then
we have other breakpoints like tablet
and what this is this is doing is like
it's by mobile first design and it
followed when I asked not to create like
form itself we just named it children so
I'm gonna copy
this and
where's our
off
so we already have Flex Flex column
minimum height screen Stuff Plus but
okay
okay and then it's
response let's see on mobile
okay it does expand to the full width
grade
now I'm gonna create an account to my
email I see this link which
I'm going to press and it takes us to
the application which means I'm already
logged in
update index page so it goes to like
courses automatically if the user is
logged in and also we can ask it to
create a header and the footer so we can
put those in the layout so I'm gonna
head over here and header should include
some kind of like navigation and the
sign out sign in button so I'm going to
ask
links to let's do courses categories and
account we're using user can go in and
make changes to the account page and
then the sign out
just in case so it doesn't use any other
stack and what I want is that it to
check if user is logged in then display
sign out and Etc and it should also give
us the functions as in from Super Bass
like sign out function and sign in
and let's see if it okay so it creates
links and those links are next links
which is great it also created a class
first session and loading so if we have
a session we're going to get account
href or sign out API okay I don't know
if that's oh maybe because we are the
helper yeah we're gonna check out and
sign in
so in this example we're using use
session hook that's correct and then
it's showing us how we can use the
header so let's go ahead
other
j6 basically one more thing to see if
all the Imports look correct all right
I'm gonna
import this here I believe it was
probably a default
import
ant not we should get in there
and
oh yeah navigation here we have
already
closed that it has created so let's just
place it here or you can also replace
probably this contains nav information
okay yeah so we don't need this anymore
I can go to either
is not a function or its return is not
iterable so use session
do you have okay
let's see if we have used session
wait this is coming from header okay so
we're already using you session
in the layout
okay so the import is actually wrong it
should have
done this
it's not iterable
so okay we can just have session
how about this
I'm gonna
update this with P okay let's see sign
out what actual word this page is not
found
getting
so instead I would suggest because we
haven't created this API I would ask
maybe is there a function we can use
okay
that is what we want
inside I know JS you can Implement okay
so it gave us
a function create a new file in
so we don't need to create an API
endpoint
but let's see if
that's the only option so just update
your header component to use a API
endpoint
okay I think I'm just gonna directly
use the super base sign out so
I'm gonna copy that one and
so here the same way we have
the client in the layout I'm gonna
do the same thing in here let's turn
this into a button
so
this has to go
and let's pass a Zuck
callback function oh not this one
all right let's see how that looks
going back to curse courses oh we need
to import
client sign out
super getting any errors in here
did you mean on click all
yep did you mean on click
and I'm gonna also do the same for the
signing we'll turn the link into
uh button
okay now let's build a search input for
our courses page so I'm gonna ask it
two generators like the input like UI
element itself also the state because as
user starts typing we also want the
search functionality to happen and the
search will be based on we can do title
and the description
and finally we can there's two options
we can search when user presses the
search itself or when they start typing
let's try first with the button so given
that will check matches against
course
was it label or
title
okay we're not displaying let's say
you can also check inside the tables on
What fields we have
the title description okay
foreign
Shadow to the
box and
rounded borders
container not sure if you'll do that but
maybe something close here's an updated
version of
courses page code
so it added that the search term State
patch courses created at
yeah we didn't ask the order but I guess
did it handle search from courses oh
interesting okay so this is how it's
doing hmm
so it's using or statement title like
search item
I'm just not sure where it's passing the
search items like courses
data and help handle as user starts
typing it's probably using this function
to update the state and let's see the
updated input itself render any other
components or links here
so I'm going to copy this this would be
the only new
piece that we're getting
so this goes after
courses title let's grab our
functions and
you can also ask a questions or see if
you're already described how this is
happening
so set courses and search term
that trigger symbol search okay
interesting so let's say if I do web and
then press enter
okay it filtered out interesting and on
update it returns all well that's
impressive now
instead
oops
let's see if we can update that as user
is typing and instead of the search the
text itself we're gonna want to display
like a lookup icon I don't know if
that's the right name
as user is
let's see if it's gonna generate SVG for
that or suggest like a library okay it
did
add a library we can also go ahead
install it
before it finishes writing the code
yeah and
install oops what is it cops look
all right some
hmm
so
I don't believe this is
oh maybe we can just add react icons
okay yeah I was gonna just ask but
so I did that and it also probably
updated the
functions so handle search
set search term
maybe in use effect
this updated version we replaced okay so
it did ignore
you just replaced it but as user is
typing
the search function that happens as the
user types all right now I'll be more
specific but first let's update this
icon
today
search term that's the name of the stage
foreign
[Music]
to trigger search
button
okay I can update that so the update
would be
simple we can just trigger
handle search after the set search item
but there might be a caveat to it that
update is delayed because when handle
search is triggered maybe the search
search term hasn't finished
updating but so data
crap so it'll be more noticeable in like
for example now I deleted all of them
and it's not
giving all the results
but yeah definitely not as I'm typing
but it's more noticeable on bigger
applications so
if I was working on this this would be
one of the things that always improve as
to make you like a production ready
application
but we can also ask what it thinks
to how
to trigger maybe this will work
search
and use your
cards
typing
automatically okay maybe that was the
key word
that I was missing uh call handle search
on input change yep it's
doing the same thing like I did it added
the handle search here
but with the update
okay
search
infuser clears
foreign
let's see if it has solution for not
updating
like updates being late to call
condition only when the input is not
empty
okay yeah this is kind of like
a hacky solution
but let's do that let's try if it
fudge course also this is not going to
work because fetch courses is
defined inside
use effect but basically how I would
resolve this is
I will trigger handle search
inside use effect
so this use effect triggers when the
page mounts right and then
here we pass search term as a dependency
and then let's pass
handle search
data okay now it's getting updated as we
delete it as well perfect
moving on to the categories we do
already have the link at the top but we
don't actually have a page for it nor do
we have categories in the database so
let's first ask it to create categories
table and maybe also in the script to
link our courses to categories
write a script or SQL editor in
please
you'll create
because right now if we go to courses it
does have a category but this is not
actually a relationship the type of this
as we can see from Super Bass is
like a variable and then this is kind of
like should be like okay character type
so it's not linked to anything there's
no relationship and let's see if
okay so we have our script create
categories table first things first we
have to do the do that then create
category Junction table and add a unit
constraint to prevent
duplicate links okay so this is for
relationship we create categories with
table ID and the name okay can you also
add
here
okay it's also going to insert all right
let's run this one first and then update
the
relationship so where's our SQL
editor
create a table
oops
[Music]
and let's
double check that it was created my
son's history perfect and then
is there a way to just new query okay
yeah I don't want to select the category
every time
okay now we're gonna create a junction
table
command enter
so failed to run SQL query frankly
constraint cannot be implemented all
right
oh that doesn't exist in courses table
Yeah I was going to ask to update
courses but maybe
provide us
no okay I should have been more specific
because it just showed us how to update
the table the two resolve this issue
make sure courses table
names match okay
foreign
so it's gonna update course table to
remove any courses that do not have
corresponding categories
okay so I ended up finding the issue and
then I ran this query it worked the
issue was that it was marking the type
was wrong in here so it was marking
course ID also as integer and then I
checked the tables to get the types and
I'm just gonna name the query create
relation oops
rename
okay now I'll ask it to in the existing
if we can update existing
courses and add categories to it but you
won't know the ID so we might have to do
that just from the table let's select
courses we should be able to directly
add the reference from here
can we browse
see
insert row
select record perfect
and I'm just gonna randomly
as a foreign key relationship so I don't
think we can have duplicates but let's
see
python for data science
okay
that should be all courses now I'm gonna
ask it when we are getting the course if
it can update the function so we are
also getting our categories with it so
that would be inside course list and as
you can see the more
we're building out the application we
have more context and it's getting
harder to every time sometimes it
remembers the com context sometimes it
doesn't relate to it so every time
passing all this information when it's
just one search input it's becoming a
little bit redundant and that's why it
is a better it still can be done so far
with this level of complexity because
we're still not in we don't have a lot
of elements but as we go into more
complex it's harder to manage and let's
without further explanation I'm gonna
tell it that this is what we're using
and say
we ran
and modify the course card so it
includes category
as so let's do a pill tag
so it fetches all the categories
initially which I don't know if we
actually need the categories maybe like
this one when we're fetching courses we
can also fetch the relation and let's
see how it's using this field
set courses okay fetch categories
filter oh this is it added for filtering
interesting
no why the colors keep changing but
okay then we have the layout let's see
where
it
uh the filters or I don't know what this
svgs for oh I said I think it's the
search one but we're using the icon from
the library already for that and oh it
updated it even filtered the courses
without
asking I just don't know where
do the filtered
categories where is this getting updated
so it should be
okay let's
try I think
course card
mm-hmm
so it wrote the code with slight
modification so I'm just gonna copy
what it updated first thing is
this array
I mean state
and I believe this search term we have
inside course page yeah
yeah so let's
add that in here same for
patching and the function
not this one but
there's also this we for fetch courses
we have that inside the use effects I'm
going to add the categories and use
effect as well for filtered courses
and
we can also oops ask it to
continue while encoding that so it can
explain what it did
and where we can use this filter courses
anyways
and they'll search
I'm gonna add this
in the end
oh and then we are zipper up it also to
update course page let's
add that mapping instead of
we don't have the class for filtered
courses that is the
oh it does it afterwards okay
so we're just passing courses of course
and we can add another
props but I'm not just gonna like
directly copy it
since then we would have to
change course card a lot as well and
we'll just
copy this one
[Music]
okay
course and
category here
courses page patch courses we don't need
two fat courses one more time but
okay we have filter search term
SVG okay that loading screen
um
course card and continue one more time
because it stopped
here
okay so after continue it's giving us
the updated course code for course card
I don't know if you picked up some
different data sets because right now
it's giving us more improved code with
more functionalities without even asking
for it so for example like ID it knows
that it has that we're going to create
or we would need to create like a
separate link for each of the cores it
also even provided like images even
though there's no
image of this like
on the and split and splash is good to
have just this like link with like you
know added classes Etc it's pretty
impressive I would say and then it added
pill for category price which it didn't
do it before and I haven't even asked
for it and even we have a button for
enroll well I would say that is really
impressive let's see if it actually
works though
okay so I'm gonna close the sides out
here we are on the course card the
difference is that it destructs your
category from here but I passed it
separately and let's import link from
next link
and
wrap
forward
save inside a link
okay courses and for ID we're gonna have
or we can get ID from here
next up I'm Gonna Leave The Styling that
we have right now
and just going to
add this one after so the title
so like that it updated
the title
to be
H2 font bold text
large okay let's leave that one let's
add
description
oh wait we have
this actually
goes
oh yeah we already had category I'm
gonna remove this
that was like the hard-coded the one
that we had
in the database and
that hardcore River was not referred to
actual table and then
after
let's say that
title we put
description then we want to add price
and the bottom
or ask it next to also
add the functionality for the button but
first let's check if the categories are
actually getting loaded can can declare
variable defined with
category interesting
constant
reassign oh we already have one
that is true yeah let's remove that
in here
okay
yes unrecognized though to fix the
categories not being mapped properly
issue I'm gonna go to courses table and
I will add a column here
let's name this categories
ID and here the key is to add the
foreign key relationship and inside here
we can select the relationship to the
categories and select the column from
public categories to reference to yeah
we're gonna identify it using the ID and
actually needed
no action uh their records existing
let's do Cascade and
save
so
I'm not moving this about the saving
this one as well so it's successful
credit categories ID let's populate it
right now so and then here we can see
this link so that means
it's linked let's see if it's gonna let
me
select okay so we can just select
directly from here
I'll just
pick one randomly
and now how can we get this data on our
site the client-side query so here we
have API docs that we can look at to
make sure
our queries look good and we're going to
take a look at it's also categorized so
for the courses we already have a Super
Bass from courses where we select
everything but let's see how we can
select the nested relationship
and that would be redrows filtering from
courses select categories so we can just
directly oh one more thing we have
so we don't need this category anymore
now that we have the link so I'm gonna
do
this and do like directly
delete from here and going back to the
API Docs
courses
let's say
ID oh so we can do from courses
select categories ID and let's see how
we can just directly access the
categories
table from there okay let's see if this
is gonna work I'm gonna update
from quotes let's do this
and let's select everything that's
related for courses and here let's have
and inside here we can grab ID and name
that's the only two Fields anyway so we
can also use like
asterisks
save it
and if we reload the page right now and
open the inspector we should see that
the categories
comes in as a
like a object and
courses page once again State and here
we have the data objects for
the question and it does include
categories now what we can do is the
reason it says unrecognized is because
we're passing in the object so we should
say we just want to get the name that
would be inside course card oh wait we
don't
need the list oh actually yeah it is
getting the oh categories comes in as an
object so okay
[Music]
but
name then if this
exists then it would be the name
is that how it is yes okay let's
save this and if we
reload right now we get the names as
well let's quickly fix also the color
of this one introduction okay so this
would be inside
course card wherever we have title I'm
just gonna
set it same color or maybe like one
shade darker as the description
okay that looks better
so even though we have authentication
and we're able to sign up users and let
them also log in we still don't have
users table where we can add other
informations about user for example
saved courses and Etc in the database so
in in this prompt we are gonna see how
we can create that table and accommodate
those courses list
okay
foreign
so giving context that we have
authentication working and we need a
script that will create this profiles
table and I would connect it to
currently existing auth users and what
it is doing is actually it's referencing
it's still generating user ID which is
going to be a unique ID but it is
referencing it from of the users that is
how we access this like users from our
authentication feature and username is
unique full okay it added some other
fields which I didn't ask to bio Avatar
time set Etc and alter tables profile it
also ended gender and birth date this
creates okay
the user ID is set up as a foreign key
to the ID okay now that we have the unit
constraint to ensure that usernames are
unique with the profiles tab once you've
created profiles you can create a new
profile Furniture when they first sign
up or log in so this is kind of like
manual approach we can improve that but
for now let's follow the manual one
first our SQL editor let's run a new
query
no rose returned I'm gonna also rename
this
and let's check if we have table
profiles here and let's insert row so
for ID it could be generated this would
be also automatic and user ID let's
select record we should only have
one record where I come from the email
yeah that's that one
username
[Music]
else
name
bio I'm not gonna
set those and see hopefully none of them
were required
okay so that's that we have this user
and now let's ask it to create an
accounts page
so we'll start building out accounts
page where user first we wanna see user
that we're logged in with and then
afterwards we want to let them change
their information this should be in the
format of a form and once they click
save they their information should be
sent to the database
and uh what else is there afterwards we
do that then we're gonna start building
out relationship to the courses so
saving saved courses and then we're
going to list that on the account page
as well but first let's get this done I
am
going to Let's this code fetches
profile from and then this is the fields
then it created a handle update profile
function now the this assumes so it's
giving us a warning that we should have
this if now you'll create the tables
before using this code perfect oh and I
think it was giving us code but that
script we already ran but let's just
in case is this the same one yeah I
think it's the same one okay I'm just
gonna
copy the first version it's giving us
inside
we don't have Pages created I can't just
create it so I'm going to create a new
file
dot Js
actually I'll create like folder instead
and then in here
your file indexed
let's copy this ex make sure everything
looks good except the Super Bass is an
import
default we don't have use user from auth
Oh see now it's giving us a different
let's ask it
so for this link create certainly all
just file would typically be
so it's created sign in sign up
etc
those files functions which we don't
need since we're using the wrapper and
update profile but I'm not seeing
use user will be used in the uses or
hook okay so here
wherever we have use user there's
nothing that's or maybe it returns
and user but I doubt that I think we can
get session from however we're getting
in the header
maybe this one has
session
[Music]
yeah Super Bass off
and we only need user
ID so
Russia
oops
so still we're gonna remove
this too
if
session
let's do obsession
ID
we're gonna find the user in our profile
table using that ID and
then we can set it I'm going to remove
this console log here
and then handle profile okay this should
look good we only have two forums and
user profile so if not here
then we can just
display that it's loading so
all right Super Bass is not defined yes
because
the function
let's
Library
yes here we have name as as you guys
remember that's what I put in and then
bio we can update the profile let me
real quick add the container here just
so it's like
equals
Flex
justify Center
items
Center and then
another one oops
gonna come after our logic
so
and let me set the width two
[Music]
so this is not
Oh by default
just if I can't
that should be you'd be like okay by
default the container does not have
margin Auto also we need to add like the
header at the top
because layout we have we can extract
that
anyways let's see if it updates bio
user is not defined okay so that's
really also need to update the Handler
profile function
that would be session user ID
updated successfully okay let's move on
to the saved courses and ask how we can
handle that
so first we need to update tables at
most likely a column for the courses and
a relationship instead it did create
user saved courses table and it added
references to both
both users and courses okay and add a
unique constraint to prevent duplicates
saved that's good alter table courses
and add save count interesting so we
know how many times the course has been
saved
create or replace function increment
update user set cost to increment
oh every time there's a new one it will
automatically update we don't have to
actually do it from the query which is
nice Implement saved count trigger
update to decrement
so that took that into consideration
and the script questioning table with my
main relationship between users and
courses at the union constraint to
prevent duplicate
um
triggers okay
now let's see how we can
take a relationship and put it into
the database so that would be for
function in Rolling course and that's
gonna take the session from Super Bass
okay I guess that's another way of
accessing session and insert user ID
course ID single there are okay the next
I'll fetch how I'll ask how we can fetch
the saved courses so let's hopefully
this script works because last time that
we created a relationship
they're not really
workouts you
query
Princess where okay auth users
hmm
I guess we could maybe a bit better to
reference profiles table
but let's see if it works with no Rose
return okay here's our user saved
courses
and these are those reference user ID
and course ID that's great okay
and let's try this function
copied and going to course card where we
have
this button and I will
add that in here we can move
this into
here actually let's so course card
Library
we don't need those
just
okay
let's save it and
should be user saved courses
let's see if what it says when we don't
to the function to trigger
await post okay yeah that's
we're not using because I was assuming
we're going to create a separate API for
that so let's just do
this
and going to
oops once again it's unrecognized it's
weird because sometimes it fetches the
category sometimes it does not
even though the query is the same like I
have not updated
versus not the course card
here
it's supposed to get it okay
so let's try if enroll works
I don't know if it's doing some kind of
cheshing because
oh well okay
sign out and roll
oh because I pressed
oh this is a link and we don't have link
yet okay I'm gonna
remove the link
session is not yeah same thing the way
we are getting a session we can
replicate
that
since that's working already for us so
and that's a hook so I'm gonna Define
outside of
the function and constant user equals we
can access user like that session
please start again okay
sir starting an objects
um
so try and then we have
let's see if it's saved
okay no I didn't say either
we are not passing the course ID and
that is you can just
take it from here
foreign
let's ask now to get all our saved
courses for us
but that would be I'm gonna pass the
name of the table
relation table
oh wait we are
Super Bass
okay
we want to
I think it's thinking I just want to run
it in SQL editor um this courses
JS page maybe that would
all right
[Music]
yeah we don't have an API
and we also don't have
this Library
oh it's trying to get
okay saved courses I'm gonna
open this to the side and here
let's add that extra State for the saved
courses let me scroll
or maybe we can create like a separate
component that would be probably better
and then import it into the account for
that I'll create in components new file
saved courses.jsx
and let's copy this
paste it and maybe user ID we already
have it on account so we're just gonna
get that from account let's remove
go over line by line
Super Bass saved courses
user ID let's pass that and fetch
if we have user
ID
course I did such a threads it should
get from here
data okay and then say it courses it's
just gonna list the titles which is good
enough for now
let's import this in the account export
default yep
user profile this will be once you have
user profile available
before that we can't
pass
user ID equals
I think we should be able to access this
from here
so I think I misspelled
saved courses yeah
your saved courses
let's see what's that Theta here because
it should
create a list are we on the okay
set saved courses course data
or if we don't have access to the I
don't think this one saves
yeah because this condition has set
saved courses but I don't know if this
one's not
you know it's Syntax for type
uid
I think I'm using
let's see what we have in user so
accounts
cone
State oh it's user underscore ID
all right that's what I'm gonna pass
okay
yes okay so now we can see the
JavaScript so fundamentals that I
enrolled in on the courses page
layout from inside of
the courses page to our
application file because we want to have
the header also on
our courses so and other pages so let's
do
this
and that should be
fine and going to pages index.js
maybe apjs would be
okay so this is where we have the
session context
provider and in here I can do
layout the
also import it at the top
so it's in
this is inside pages so
find uh it's probably default okay yeah
great going back to courses now if I'm
enrolled in JavaScript fundamentals
I'm still not sure why this is not
getting this relation loaded
try one thing
okay now it's there weird
so if I'm oh I'm already enrolled in
JavaScript fundamentals let's see if we
can ask it to update this button and
show like enrolled or maybe like a check
mark
um
and I think is the react icon Library
yeah react
and let's give it the name of the table
just in case it goes down a different
route and that would be user saved
courses
create also a bookmark icon so instead
of having a text of enroll we can just
press that to save a class and probably
removing that and a floating loaded and
when the button loads it checks
redirected look okay I'm gonna update
the user part because every time I feel
like it
gives us different ways of checking user
Ascension but we already have a way that
we figured out it's working for us I'm
just going to use that and okay so it's
supposed to fetch the courses and check
which ones in the cooler which course ID
we have and we are passing course ID as
a prop so let me copy code right now
enroll like button it's just inside
course card so I'm going to create a new
file for that let's see what it needs
okay
so instead of checking user session I'm
also going to pass
user
ID
yeah because we don't want to check on
every course card if you have a session
or not we can just pass it from there so
removing oops
removing this one
updating Super Bass
and this is in yeah going back Library
react icons use effective State that's
there enrolled set enrolled okay and
then
no user user
ID
same thing
here and then the these are the
dependencies I'm also going to update
if user ID or course ID changes we have
to obviously
refetch this data redirect you actually
we can redirect them to logging
it's true
actually let me
I'm gonna do this this is here
replace it everywhere
except
oh no not this one
okay this is already replaced so I'm
just gonna
do it myself and
so it inserts save the course if not
already saved
okay
and then it updates set enrolled
otherwise removes or delete or inserts
up gray and then
the icon gets updated accordingly that
should be fine let's import this into
course card
and oh we also need
we don't need on click anymore because
it's gonna do that
and let's see so of course ID
going to be equal to ID here
and then user ID
that one we can also pass it down from
courses index
we don't already have that array
okay
just gonna
move this here
foreign
equals
let's see if this is the case
um inside okay so once we map and now
let's go back to course card
get user ID from here so we can pass it
in here
the one issue is that if user ID hasn't
been
loaded
should still update
new session
okay
import statement at the top
okay so I have this
enrolled so it's showing that I'm
enrolled in here I wonder what it's
supposed to show when because we do have
the logic
bookmark
so maybe because it doesn't have a color
or
oh yep outline works
great
that's actually all this to the left
load this categories get updated so
maybe there's some kind of caching issue
that
oh I would note to like double check if
categories are not fetched then refetch
it that should solve it so this would be
it for this project and to quickly recap
what we did so we we set up this course
app using make sure yes Super Bass
Tailwind reused react icon for our icon
library and then view of the other
libraries after that we set up a schema
to Define courses categories and user we
did the setting of the database meaning
like putting some dummy data for testing
in it we also checked I'm using LGBT
what like file structure should look
like what schema should look like even
it generated data for us and we utilized
it also to for styling creating this
like responsive grid elements all this
like colors and Etc we implemented
authenticate station and then after that
we created users table where we store
more information about the user users
can log in using email and password and
we also try to came across obviously
there are some issues that we try to
debug using the documentation of
superbase itself and chat GPT we created
this like layout that right now it only
has a header that and then layout is
conditional meaning if we we're on a
signing page it's not going to show up
also we for the courses page we have
categories page we created relationships
in between those and then we create a
relationship between user and the
courses we created functionality for
user to save the courses or remove the
course and for them to go to their
account get their information get their
saved classes and also update their
profile like future future changes that
I would do is probably on the accounts
page I would add all the fields that we
have right now in the table like I think
there was the image there was like
gender year
Etc and then for the save courses maybe
I'll modify I'll get more information
about the course and I'll also give like
a remove button that they can like
remove the course like their enrollment
and going back to courses page yeah we
also did this search where we can filter
out our database either like
descriptions or the name of the courses
these categories I still have to fix
that but we also have pricing and we
wanting like filtering behind the scenes
like functions exist but we haven't
actually added filters so for example
price filter would be a good feature to
like practice on next and going forward
these are some of the aspects of
development that I would consider using
chargpt as an assistant first one would
be called optimization technique so what
are some of the ways to optimize
performance in this application is one
thing you can ask what are some of the
ways to fetch this kind of data faster
and or how to test the performance
itself is something that you can ask and
not only performance but in general if
you're using jazz or if we have never
used it for example it might suggest
that as a tool that you can use and ask
like guidelines or list of like a
template of how you can test certain
weather components or API requests or
Etc also very helpful in writing a
readme or technical documentation for
example in this our case like I would
say based on the code that was generated
in the this conversation so that way it
kind of like parses through and takes
like the whole conversation as a context
generated a readme that at least step by
set guide on how to set up the project
so we did set set it up but we also want
to see step-by-step guide and also I'm
gonna add readme to Output this project
in a GitHub repository and the link
would be shared so also you can go over
the readme there and set it up yourself
and if I set up this boiler played code
very simple P probably next thing I
would do is just have a list of things
that I thought about or could be a good
practice to follow along at the
professional like website or working
application would need so you can ask it
to now in this case before that it was
your senior architect to a software
engineer now you can ask it to be a
product manager and tell it that you
already wrote some code and write it
like the other tasks that would be
needed to be accomplished and what I'll
do is probably it's going to at least
task in bullet points so I would maybe
like take this put it in notion and have
like a zapier integration that that in
from the notion payroll database it
automatically creates jira Asana
whichever is your task management tool
tasks and then you can go over the board
you can even assign it to other people
or for yourself to have a good way of
continuing working on this or if you're
new to full stack development you kind
of see this template of what are the
list of things that need to be done and
hopefully you enjoyed this tutorial you
learned how to use chat GPT but also
some other Concepts there and thank you
for watching